c'est aujourd'hui un retraité paisible
c'était en 75 le patron de
l'antiterrorisme à la dst jambaque
outils enquête à l'époque sur les
raisons palestine en europe avait de
carlos il ne sait encore venir tout
commence avec la fille nature de cet
homme michel non car bâle un libanais
l'attesté le surveille le photographier
même sans le savoir ici en compagnie de
carcans sous puis l'interpellent et
l'interrogent
mon quart by me parle très très peu à ce
moment là il a tout juste donner son
identité
il n'a pas reconnu sa mission et
refusent de nous donner des
renseignements je peux je qualifierais
d'opérationnel puis sous la menace d'une
expulsion nous car bâle parle libre le
nom de l'inconnu de la photo carlos les
guides les policiers
tout livre en parle dans l'appartement
les inspecteurs de la dst trouve des
étudiants sud américain et carlos qui
désignait par mukamal tue son complice
libanais tu es abat froidement les deux
fonctionnaires de police
les hommes de jean baklouti n'était pas
armé ce soir là
l'opération a été on ne peut plus mal
monté peut-être c'est vrai qu'on aurait
dû prendre d'autres précautions mais
vous savez pour un flic c'est après coup
très souvent commençait pas soit qu'il
ya une bavure échos n'aurait pas dû
faire comme cela mais voilà carlos s'est
échappé sa chance pour la police il a
laissé des empreintes sa traque commence
vingt-deux ans après carlos ses avocats
dénoncent un complot politique
il s'appuie sur les confidences d'un
ancien agent des services secrets
israéliens le mossad étaient présents
rue toullier la rue toullier est un
crime de haute trahison des temps de
hauts fonctionnaires français ont
organisé avec des agents du mossad
représente donc une puissance étrangère
la provocation de la rue toullier bon
pour entraîner la rupture des accords
entre les organisations palestiniennes
et l'état français
de sa cellule qu'il y a quelques
semaines carlos a même écrit au
président de la cour d'assises qui va le
juger
il dénonce dans cette lettre un complot
sioniste jambes à l'outil luis nani
admiration l'hyène pour ce terroriste
d'un prêt d'être acquis pour 15 ans il
suivra simplement le procès avec
attention